[MUSIC PLAYING]
PRABHAKAR RAGHAVAN: At G Suite,
we're obsessed with the idea
that computers should constantly
raise the bar on what they
can get done in
at the mundane so
that our users, your
employees, have more and more
time to focus on
truly creative work.
And today, three of our apps are
on over a billion smartphones.
And we have over 3
million paying businesses
that use the G Suite.
Here are three examples of
recent early adopted programs
that we've done.
Each of these apps
is something that
was built for enterprises
only, the Jamboard, App Maker,
Google Cloud Search.
Every one of these is an
enterprise-only product.
Google Drive today has over 800
million monthly active users.
I'll be making five
announcements now.
First, Team Drives goes into
general availability today,
and it lets teams easily
share content in their drive
and manage the sharing.
I'm pleased to announce
general availability for Google
Vault for drive content.
I see a few people are
excited about that as well.
Thank you.
That's all very well for
content in the cloud.
But most of my content sits
in on-premise files servers.
What do I do about that?
I'm excited to announce
that we are acquiring
Vancouver-based App Bridge.
App Bridge is a company
that builds connectors
from on-premise file servers
to siphon that content up
into Google Drive.
Google's machine learning magic
will build a predictive model
for who you are
and your activity
and serve up that file
before you even ask for it.
We call this quick access.
JONATHON ROCHELLE: We
rebuilt Google Hangouts
with a focus on making teams
productive-- completely rebuilt
to be an intelligent
messaging app for teams.
But in the new Hangouts
chat, we've added rooms.
Rooms are a central place for
team and project discussions.
So what you're seeing here
is the new Hangouts Meet,
our enterprise solution
for video meetings.
SPEAKER 3: The Jamboard knows
that there's a meeting going on
and automatically
presents a prompt.
And with one click, TJ
can join the meeting
and present the
Jamboard to the meeting.
PRABHAKAR RAGHAVAN:
We decided that it
was time for Gmail to
have add-on capability
because people
were wasting simply
too much time going from their
primary work surface, which
could be Gmail, digressing
over to a distraction,
and then by the time they come
back, 20 minutes are gone.
SPEAKER 4: Now remember,
he's still in Gmail.
He's never left the application.
And he is able to fill out
the invoice entirely in there.
Boom.
He sends the invoice,
and he's done.
It was that easy.
PHIL GARLAND: Well, we've
seen many positive impacts
of our move to G Suite.
But one in particular
I'd like to highlight
is when we asked the
question around productivity
and productivity
improvements, the estimated
average productivity
enhancement and gain per week
was nearly nine hours.
PRABHAKAR RAGHAVAN: It's
our [INAUDIBLE] showcase
the Gmail add-ons.
And we've been working with
a bunch of other partners
to build out
exciting new add-ons.